كان حصار مشدد علينا ما كانش احد يستطيع
ان يخرج من خارج المبنى وفي خلال حصار تم
قنص ثلاث افراد عننا في داخل المبنى مش في
داخل سور المستشفى لا في داخل الم واحد
ممرض واثنين عاملات واحد قصفه على السطح
واحد في داخل غرفته والثانيه وهي في داخل
المستشفى ماشيه على بتروح من مكان الى
مكان وضعنا كان صعب جدا جدا ما كنا ما
كانش بصلنا امدادات
لا سواء تغذيه ولا اي شيء احنا كلنا
قائمين بذاتنا وما توقفنا عن العمل الا
انه في عننا
مشاكل مشاكلنا خاصه في اذا بتتكلم على
فيما يتعلق بالحوامل والولادات احنا ما
عندنا
سلر احنا عشان انا بدي اشتغل اولد زي ما
انت شايف المستشفى كيف ظلمه كله ما فيش نن
شغالين على اللدات تمام ننا امبارح اول
امبارح اشترينا سولار من السوق السودا
اشترينا اللتر ب 20 شيكل شحده باضعاف
اضعاف سعره الطبيعي وبالتالي عشان انا بدي
اعمل قسريه لازم اشغل المولدات عشان اطباء
يشتغلوا على الكهرباء على الضوء احيانا
بضطر نشتغل على كهربه يد تمام او على نور
الجوال عشان تعمل قيصريه او تولد ست وتعمل
لها غرز او تقوم بالخدمه التامه هذه مشكله
كبيره بالنسبه لنا النسبه الثانيه كمان
المشكله الثانيه عدم توفر الاكسجين وخاصه
للحالات اللي بتحتاج للاطفال حديسي
الولاده لو كان في عندهم اي مشكله بسيطه و
بيحتاجوا الى اكسجين او الاكسجين للسيدات
اللي بيحتاجوا قيصريه وبحتاج لازم تعمل
لهم التخدير الكلي والتخدير دير الكلي
يحتاج الى الاكسجين فبن طر نعمل معظم
الحالات الولادات القيصريه عن طريق اللي
هو السبايدر انستيزيا اللي بموه بالعام
بالعاميه البنج النصفي هذه مشكله كبيره
بالاضافه الى انه احنا خلال اليوم الث3 لم
يصلنا اي شيء لا من الوقود ولا من
المستهلكات الطبيه ولا من الادويه ولا
ادويه التخدير لان رفت على النفات في امور
اخرى فيما يتعلق بالجراحات وخصه جراحات
العظام اللي الاجهزه اللي بنشتغل عليها
تقريبا استنفذنا كلها